die allseits erwartete ukrainische
Gegenoffensive gegen die Russen hat
lange auf sich warten lassen doch nun
geht die Ukraine vom sogenannten shaping
des Schlachtfelds zur kämpferischen
Aufklärung über und sucht aktiv nach
Schwachstellen in den russischen Linien
die Russen berichten bereits dass es nun
losgehe und auch westliche offizielle
geben dies Verhalten zu
9.7.2023 die Streitkräfte der Ukraine
befreiten mehr als 15 Siedlungen und
rückten 5 bis 17 km tief in die Front in
Richtung saporisha vor entlang der
gesamten Linie wird heftig gekämpft das
russische Kommando hat bereits bis zu
70% der Reserven im Süden aktiviert
bisher haben die ukrainische
Streitkräfte die für die Offensive
aufgestellten hauptkampfeinheiten noch
nicht eingesetzt nach den Informationen
von der Frauen zu urteilen könnte dies
in den nächsten Tagen geschehen
russischen Militär zufolge die sich in
der Kampfzone befinden hat die
ukrainische Armee damit begonnen
schockeinheiten in die Stadt zu schicken
die die Verteidigung der russischen
Streitkräfte durchbrechen und so die
gesamte Verteidigung in diesem
Frontabschnitt zu Fall bringen können
die Streitkräfte der Ukraine haben dabei
erfolgreich die erste Verteidigungslinie
der russischen Streitkräfte an der
Südfront durchbrochen die russischen
Truppen konnten einen schnellen
Durchbruch und eine Einkesselung
verhindern aber sie können ihre Stellung
nicht halten und ziehen sich langsam
entlang fast der gesamten kontaktlinie
zurück die Ukrainer sind sehr gut
vorbereitet aber es ist zu früh um zu
sagen wie es ausgehen wird Mark Milly
Vorsitzender des vereinigten
Generalstabs der US-Streitkräfte in den
Medien war bereits seit Monaten von
einer Kampagne die Rede die aber lange
nicht in Gang gekommen ist es gab kleine
Operationen Angriffe auf russische
Treibstoff und Munitionsdepots
gelegentliche Anschläge auf der Creme
und sogar Übergriffe auf russisches
Territorium z.B in Gebiet Belgrad und
natürlich die gewaltige ukrainische
verteidigungsoperation in bachmut aber
es gab bisher noch keine klaren
Anzeichen für eine großangelegte gegen
Offensive Anfang Juni 2023 waren schwere
westliche Waffen wie die Leopards oder
amerikanische Bradleys noch nicht in die
Schlacht gezogen jetzt aber meine lieben
zusch führerscheint Bewegung in die
Angelegenheit zu kommen also stehen die
Sterne nun günstig damit die Ukraine
ihren großen Befreiungsschlag wagt mit
Sternen meinen wir natürlich das Wetter
die Konsistenz der Böden die Belaubung
der Wälder den Füllstand der
Munitionsdepots und viele andere
unzählige Parameter des
bereitschaftsgrades sowohl der
ukrainischen als auch der russischen
Streitkräfte nach den vielen Videos die
wir über den russischen ukrainischen
Krieg veröffentlicht haben haben wir
hier bei visualpolitik im Vorfeld
dagegen Offensive lange Zurückhaltung
geübt schließlich hat die Armee der
Ukraine selbst umruhe und
Verschwiegenheit gebeten aber natürlich
haben wir nicht geschlafen sondern
unzählige Informationen aus einer
Vielzahl von Quellen angesammelt und
ausgewertet und auch wenn aus ihnen
schon sehr viel hervorgehen wollten wir
aus strategischen Gründen Liebe noch
etwas abwarten tja doch dann wurde der
Staudamm bei Norbert kachowka gesprengt
und nachdem die Angestellten
Wassermassen nun die Region her sondern
auf schreckliche Weise geflutet haben
wollen auch wir unsere analysewelle auf
euch loslassen nicht weil der Dammbruch
irgendeinen gamechanger aus dem
militärischer Sicht darstellen würde
sondern weil er wieder nur eines klar
macht dieser von Putin losgetretener und
von seinen skrupellosen Lakaien
durchgeführte Menschen und auch
naturfeindliche Irrsinn muss endlich ein
Ende haben oder vielmehr eine endgültige
Lösung keine aufgeschobene aus der neues
Unheil erwachsen kann keine Angst die
hintergründete Damen Sprengung werden
wir im Laufe dieses Videos noch
ausführlich klären wichtiger ist jedoch
unser Hauptthema die gegen Offensive
denn natürlich haben sich bei uns nicht
nur Emotionen aufgestaut sondern vor
allem schon zu viele interessante
Erkenntnisse die wir euch nicht länger
vorenthalten können am Ende dieses
Videos werdet ihr daher den kompletten
Überblick haben alle relevanten Zahlen
und Fakten Strategien und Szenarien
Waffen und Taktiken also lasst uns
loslegen warum hat sich die ukrainische
gegen Offensive eigentlich so lange
verzögert mit welchen genauen Ressourcen
können die Ukraine operieren um sie
durchzuführen wie stark konnten sie die
Fähigkeiten ihrer Armee verbessern und
hat US Außenminister Anthony blinken
wirklich recht mit seiner Behauptung
in the world and many believed today
many Brushless
ich meine ist das wirklich ernst gemeint
oder einfach nur ein flotter Spruch
schließlich zeichneten ja die
sogenannten Pentagon leaks kein
besonders rosiges Bild vom Zustand der
ukrainischen Armee wenn die Zahlen aus
den angeblich durch gesegten Pentagon
Dokumenten nämlich der Wahrheit
entsprechend würden wäre es für key viel
besser über haupt keine
offensiv-operation durchzuführen
schließlich war dort nur von einem
Dutzend verfügbarer Manöver Brigaden die
Rede und genau daraus ergibt sich die
Gretchenfrage die sich die ganze Welt
stellt was können wir vom ukrainischen
Gegenangriff überhaupt erwarten ist das
ganze nur ein Bluff oder könnte es sein
das ist die Ukraine mit Hilfe ihrer
Verbündeten insgeheim geschafft hat eine
viel größere Streitmacht aufzustellen
als Pentagon Liga die Welt glauben
lassen wollen stimmt es wie manche
Analysten behaupten dass die ukrainische
Armee heute eine militärische Kraft
darstellt die in Europa ihresgleichen
sucht in diesem Video werden wir all
diese und noch viele weitere kritische
Fragen beantworten und eines kann ich
Euch schon jetzt garantieren die heutige
Fahrt wird heftig werden nichts für
schwache Nerven und unaufmerksame
Gemüter
also schnat euch gut an und lasst eure
Motoren schon mal warm laufen so wie die
Ukraine die ihrer Panzer und apropos
Warmlaufen bevor wir loslegen verrate
ich euch noch wie ich meinen Körper und
Geist jeden Morgen mit einer Bewegungs-
und ernährungstechnisch optimierten
Routine auf Touren bringen als
aufmerksame visuelle Politik Zuschauer
habt ihr vielleicht schon bemerkt dass
ich in den letzten Monaten etwas
abgenommen habe vielleicht sieht man es
mir ja sogar an aber viel wichtiger ist
dass ich mich so einfach viel fitter
fühle letztes Jahr hat meine
Arbeitsbelastung aufgrund des Krieges
enorm zugenommen und ich hatte
Schwierigkeiten den Stress auf gesunde
Weise zu kompensieren die Folgen waren
Bewegungsmangel schlechte Ernährung und
Fettpölsterchen ich musste also etwas
unternehmen als erstes habe ich meine
Morgenroutine umgestellt vor dem
Frühstück gibt es jetzt erstmal eine
Portion LG Bonn um Stoffwechsel und
Kreislauf in Schwung zu bringen und
Flüssigkeit und wichtige Nährstoffe
nachzutanken danach kommt eine Runde
Krafttraining und dann übe ich Proteine
um das Muskelwachstum zu unterstützen
das heißt diese Routine ersetzt keine
ausgewogene Ernährung aber sie hilft mir
dabei viel gesünder und unbelasteter in
den Tag zu starten ich fühle mich satt
aber ohne dieses typische low nach einem
gewöhnlichen Frühstück wie früher denn
man Insulinspiegel bleibt schön konstant
und das Ergebnis kann sich wahrlich
sehen lassen innerhalb von fünf Monaten
bin ich von 104 auf 93 Kilo runter aber
was viel wichtiger ist ich bin nicht nur
sechs Kilogramm Körperfett los geworden
an ihre Stelle sind auch noch gut zwei
Kilogramm Muskelmasse getreten das sagt
zumindest die Messung aber ich denke man
sieht auch und vor allem fühle ich mich
nun wesentlich fitter ausgewogener und
belastbarer aber warum gerade LG Bonn
nun es ist Keto freundlich hat keine
künstlichen Zusatzstoffe und ist sehr
einfach in der Anwendung seine 75
wertvoll Inhaltsstoffe wurden aus echtem
natürlichen veganen Nahrungsmitteln wie
Erbsen oder Soja gewonnen und sind in
hoher Bio Verfügbarkeit vorhanden so
dass sie besonders gut vom Körper
aufgenommen werden können außerdem
schmeckt es auch noch gut mir zumindest
natürlich darf man es wie alles nicht
überdosieren sollte auf Allergene achten
und vor allem nicht einnehmen wenn man
schwanger ist oder stillt das ist jetzt
bei mir zum Glück nicht der Fall aber im
Ernst ich empfehle euch auf jeden Fall
mal eine Ernährungsberatung zu machen um
festzustellen was in der braucht um euch
besser zu fühlen und gesünder zu leben
mir persönlich hilft die vorhin genannte
Kombination gleich nach dem Aufstehen am
besten schreibt mir doch in die
Kommentare wie eure Morgenroutine
aussieht und wenn sie nicht zu ideal ist
wie ihr sie auf Vordermann bringen
möchtet passen dazu bietet LG born
unsere Community nämlich ein exklusives
Angebot wenn du auf den Link in der
Videobeschreibung klickst erhältst du
bei Abschluss eines monatlichen Abos
einen kostenlosen Jahresvorrat an
Vitamin D3 und K5 und 5 praktische one
travel Packs für unterwegs gratis dazu
neukunden erhalten außerdem ist age und
welcome inklusive schicke
Aufbewahrungsdose und einen praktischen
Shaker zur Monats Packung dazu das Ganze
ist zwar ein Abo aber ohne
laufzeitverbindung jederzeit nach
Belieben anpassbar und kündbar unten mit
einer sehr praktischen 20 Tage Geld
zurück Garantie stellst du also nach
drei Monaten fest dass es nicht zu Dir
passt bekommst du das Geld für die erste
Bestellung einfach wieder zurück ohne
dass du dafür irgendwelche Gründe
angeben musst also worauf wartest du
noch probier AG one doch einfach mal
ganz unverbindlich aus und bring deine
Ernährung und Routine auch auf
Vordermann und wenn du das erledigt hast
lasst uns wieder zur Beantwortung
unserer brennenden Fragen kommen was
können wir vom großen ukrainischen
Gegenangriff erwarten könnte es sein
dass die Ukraine es geschafft hat eine
viel größere Streitmacht aufzustellen
als allgemein bekannt ist aufgepasst
[Applaus]
[Musik]
die Verluste die Verzweiflung das Leid
die Zerstörung der Krieg zieht sich in
die Länge und ein Ende ist nicht in
Sicht das Problem ist das ist immer
schwieriger werden wirklich
verteidigungsanstrengungen aufrecht zu
erhalten aus diesem Grund bereitet die
Ukraine seit Monaten eine gegen
Offensive vor die im besten Fall das
Ende aller Expansionsbestrebungen des
Krems in der Ukraine bedeuten könnte und
im schlimmsten Fall
Friedensverhandlungen erzwingen wird es
handelt sich um eines der vier Szenarien
die wir euch in einem früheren Video
über das Ende des Krieges in der Ukraine
vorgestellt haben die Vorbereitung
dagegen Offensive hat jedoch viel länger
gedauert als die meisten erwartet haben
und die Frage ist warum nur die
Hauptgründe sind die folgende
[Musik]
auf der einen Seite haben wir den am
wenigsten zu beeinflussenden aber
dennoch sehr wichtigen Faktor das Wetter
die Witterung im Jahr 2023 hat dazu
geführt dass der ukrainische Boden nach
dem Winter länger braucht um aufzutauen
dieser dazu geführt dass der für dieses
Gebiet so charakteristische Schlamm
länger anhielt als im langjährigen
Mittel und ist überrascht nicht dass die
rasputizer der schlammige Boden die
Bewegung von Militärfahrzeugen ernsthaft
behindern kann dies ist natürlich für
beide Seiten von Nachteil vor allem aber
für denjenigen der schnell im Gelände
vorstoßen will um gegnerische
Verteidigungsstellungen zu überrennen
oder abzuschneiden auch bei der
Ausbildung des Soldaten ist es zu
Verzögerung gekommen in den letzten
Monaten wurden Zehntausende Ukraine
schon Soldaten von den NATO Armenien
ausgebildet die Ausbildung soll die
ukrainischen Truppen in die Lage
versetzen unter anderem gepanzerte Kampf
Fahrzeuge vom Typ Striker und Bradley
Panzer hobbiten vom Typ Paladin sowie
Leopard und Challenger Panzer wirksam
einzusetzen aber zu den Waffensystemen
kommen wir später noch in aller
Ausführlichkeit tatsache ist das die
Ausbildung etwas langsamer verläuft als
erwartet
[Musik]
ein weiterer Faktor der die Verzögerung
dagegen offensiver erklärt ist die
Lieferung der westlichen Waffen selbst
in der Tat ist dies vielleicht sogar der
wichtigste Grund
[Musik]
ein Großteil der von den Verbündeten im
Jahr 2023 zugesagten militärischen
Ausrüstung ist noch nicht oder mit
Verspätung in die Ukraine eingetroffen
so waren beispielsweise von den fast 300
zugesagten Panzern darunter auch Leopard
2 bis Mitte Mai nur etwa 100 geliefert
worden und von den rund 700 übrigen
gepanzerten Kampf Fahrzeugen wie den
Bradleys waren nur etwa 300 angekommen
logischerweise konnte die gegen
Offensive nicht stattfinden wenn die
Waffen noch unterwegs waren das würde
überhaupt keinen Sinn machen zumal ihre
Verteilung und die Errichtung der
unterstützenden Logistik auch eine Menge
Zeit in Anspruch nehmen es handelt sich
um ein klassisches skalierungsproblem
aber es gibt nicht nur um die
Waffensysteme selbst auch die Lieferung
von Munition verliefen langsamer als
erwartet dabei müssen wir
berücksichtigen dass die Ukraine wie ein
ukrainischer Parlamentarier verriet
täglich zwischen 6000 8000
schussverfeuert das bedeutet dass die
Ukraine für eine gegen Offensive bei der
sich der munitionsbedarf mit Sicherheit
vervielfachen wird zunächst in der Nähe
des Schlachtfelds genügend Munition
anhäufen müssen um nicht Gefahr zu
laufen dass sie ausgeht vor allem müssen
sowohl die Munition als auch die Waffen
so deponiert und stationiert werden dass
der Feind nichts über ihre Lage und
Anzahl erfährt
nur so kann man gewährleisten dass er
keine geeigneten Gegenmaßnahmen ergreift
bedenkt also bitte dass dies vor allem
eine enorme planerische und logistische
Herausforderung darstellt
auch weil es sich nicht um eine statisch
Angelegenheit handelt die einmal
erledigt wird und dann einfach läuft
nein militärlogistik ist ein unglaublich
dynamisches Organisationsproblem dessen
Lösungen sich jederzeit hyperflexibel an
die sich ständig im Fluss befindlichen
Umstände anpassen muss in jedem Krieg
gehört die Logistik zu den Dingen die
von Außenstehenden normalerweise als
zweit oder drittrangig angesehen werden
aber es ist eben die Logistik die im
Augenblick der Wahrheit über sie oder
Niederlage entscheiden kann wenn Ihr
System nicht perfekt ist oder man sie
auch nur für kurze Zeit aus den Augen
verliert können die Folgen für die
gesamten Streitkräfte katastrophal sein
aber warum ist dies gerade für die
Ukraine ein derartiges Problem nun die
internationalen Lieferungen ihrer
Verbündeten haben ist der Ukraine zwar
möglich über groß und einigermaßen gut
ausgerüstete Streitkräfte zur Verfügung
gleichzeitig haben sie aber auch dazu
geführt dass ihre Ausrüstung unglaublich
heterogen ist und die Armee durch eine
Vielzahl an Systemen Modifikation
Anpassungen und Provisorien im Chaos zu
versinken droht aus logistischer Sicht
bedeutet die Vorbereitung von
Streitkräften die in kürzester Zeit und
von Dutzenden von Ländern ausgerüstet
werden dass man in der Lage sein muss
einen Leopard 2 einen T-72 und einen
Brad League gleichzeitig auszurüsten und
zu reparieren und glaub mir das ist
schon bei einem homogenen perfekt
abgestimmten Arsenal keine leichte
Aufgabe alles wird unglaublich
kompliziert werden von der Munition bis
zu den Ersatzteilen einschließlich der
Mechaniker des Transports oder
Verwaltung der Ausrüstung die zu
Reparatur ins Ausland geschickt wird der
Knackpunkt ist das dieses
Operationssystem wie eine gut
geschmiertes Getriebe mit präzisions
Uhrwerk laufen muss wenn die gegen
Offensive von Erfolg gekrönt sein soll
und das mein Leben wieso soll Politik
Zuschauer braucht eben Zeit das Getriebe
muss extra gut geschmiert sein und das
Uhrwerk super präzise eingestellt der
derzeitige Ansatz bei dem jedes Land
stückweise keine waffenbatterie spendet
entwickelt sich für die ukrainische
Streitkräfte rasch zu einem logistischen
Albtraum da jede Batterie eine eigene
ausbildungswartungs- und Logistikkette
erfordert viele der ukrainischen Waffen
aus dem Westen warten außerhalb der
Frontlinie auf Reparaturen
Artilleriegeschütze müssen hunderte von
Meilen vom Schlachtfeld entfernt in
nato-gebiet repariert werden nun denn
trotz der Verzögerung der lang
erwarteten ukrainischen gegen Offensive
fragen sich viele von euch
wahrscheinlich wie wird sich diese
Militäroperation eigentlich entwickeln
wenn sie denn mal losgeht auf welche
Trümpfe stützen sich die Ukraine bei
ihrer Durchführung worin liegen ihre
Stärken und was sind ihre Schwächen im
Vergleich zu den Russen nun wir haben
euch in vergangenen Videos bereits
einige Details genannt aber in diesem
Video werden wir alles noch mal viel
genauer unter die Lupe nehmen und euch
dann den großen übergeordneten Überblick
liefern also Hörzu
das Ukraine
[Musik]
die große ukrainische Gegenoffensive
scheint vor der Tür zu stehen und dies
könnte das Vorspiel darstellen 23 mai
2023 Kämpfe in russischer Grenzregion
gehen nach Einmarsch in den zweiten Tag
31 Mai 2023 Ukraine Krieg kommt nach
Moskau und Angriffe auf beide
Hauptstädte mit all diesen Maßnahmen
wird ein zweifaches Ziel verfolgt
einerseits tragen Sie dazu bei dem Moral
der Russen und Putins eigene Führung in
den Augen der eigenen Bevölkerung zu
untergraben selbst im russischen
Staatsfernsehen wurde die Regierung in
Propaganda Sendungen für ihren
mangelhaften Schuss der Grenzgebiete
kritisiert und später würden wir uns
doch mal an was eigentlich hilft gegen
dazu zu sagen hat denn während die
ukrainische Armee mit gepanzerten
Fahrzeugen in den Regionen und jetzt uns
aber sicher angreifen bekämpfen sich die
Russen immer mehr untereinander in der
russischen Region Belgorod sind die die
relias der russischen Opposition auf dem
portemasch und Wagner beschuldigt gerade
die russische Armee absichtlich auf
seine eigenen Zöllner zu schießen
Wagner nimmt russischen Kommandeur
gefangen während die viele zwischen
pregorian unter Armee eskaliert in einem
Video das aufbringos in Social Media
Kanälen gepostet wurde erzählt
oberstleutner Thomas
72 russischen Brigade einem Vernehmer
dass er in betrunkenen Zustand seinen
Truppen befohlen habe auf einen Wagner
Convoi zu schießen in den Aufnahmen die
an Clips von Kriegsgefangenen Soldaten
erinnern sagte wenn er mit den er habe
aus persönliche Abneigung gegen Wagner
gehandelt und sich dann entschuldigt
gefangengenommene offiziell Wagen das
soll nach folterten mich und strahlen
Panzer der russischen Armee ein
ranghoher Offizier der russischen Armee
der von der wagnergruppe gefangen
gehalten wurde hat in einem brisanten
Monolog der die wachsende Luft zwischen
den russischen Militär und denen der
Ukraine Captain privat Medizin offen
liegt erklärt dass er in der
Gefangenschaft gefoltert wurde und die
Mitglieder der Gruppe Waffen darunter
Panzer von seiner Einheit gestohlen
hätten Obermann wenn ihr Weg hinkommt
oder 72 unabhängigen russischen
motorisierten schützen Brigade der sich
auf einem Video dafür entschuldigt hatte
dass er seinen Männern befohlen habe auf
die wagnergruppe in der Nähe von
sagte das Geständnis sei unter Zwang
abgelegt worden ich wurde gefangen
genommen im Keller festgehalten und auf
eine Art und Weise schikaniert wie ein
verbitterter russischer Soldat einen
Gefangenen ukrainischen Soldaten nicht
schikanieren würde das muss man sich mal
auf der Zunge zergehen lassen der Chef
einer privaten zöllnertruppe verhaftet
einfach in einem Akt der Selbstjustiz
einen ihm unliebsamen Kommandeur der
staatsarmee führt ihn öffentlich als
schießwütigen truppenwolf vor und Ernte
dafür in Russland auch noch reichlich
Applaus von Seiten der Patrioten dieser
Vorfall spiegelt auch beeindruckende
Weise den aktuellen Zustand des
russischen Staatswesens wieder und für
den deutlichen Trend seines Zerfalls vor
Augen die staatliche Autorität und
offizielle hoheitlichkeit weicht der
Willkür der Wolf und die üben schon mal
den ein oder anderen Staatsstreich im
kleinen quasi als Machtdemonstration und
um auszutesten ob man nicht noch einen
Schritt weiter gehen kann
die Nerven auf russische Seite liegen
blank weil das zweite Ziel der
ukrainischen Vorbereitungsmaßnahmen so
gut wie erreicht ist nämlich den Gegner
dazu zu zwingen seine Kapazitäten und
seine Aufmerksamkeit zu fragmentieren
vielleicht sogar wichtige Gebiete an der
Front in der Ukraine ungeschützt zu
lassen 8 September 2023 Wagner zieht
sich aus bachmut zurück während die
Ukraine in die Offensive geht in bachgut
haben die ukrainischen Streitkräfte
gestern die Kämpfe an den Flanken der
Stadt
fortgesetzte stellvertretende
ukrainische Verteidigungsministerin
sagte das Russland Truppen aus anderen
Positionen heranführen muss im
militärjagoon nennt man das Shaping man
formt sich die Front für seine kommende
Operation zurecht und Taste die
Schwachstellen des Gegners ab die
Ukraine wissen ganz genau das Russland
derzeit nicht über ausreichende
Kapazitäten verfügt um 1.300 km
Frontlinie ausreichen sofortifizieren
und dass die russische Armeeführung jede
Orte an denen ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit
des ukrainischen Vorgehensweise sehr gut
auswählen muss der ukrainische
generalstoff schätzt dass handstärke der
russischen Truppen derzeit circa 350.000
beträgt davon waren etwa 200.000 für
aktive Operationen in der Süd- und
Ostukraine im Rahmen der Winteroffensive
vorgesehen die kürzlicher ohne
nennenswerter Ergebnisse endete außer
das zehntausende wenn ich gar 100.000
Mann getötet und verwundet worden die
Front an der Enz Süden und Osten aktive
Kampfhandlungen laufen und wollen
ukrainische Angriff erwartet wird ist
etwa 600 km lang der Fluss wird bei
einer natürliche Barriere die die
Angriffsmöglichkeiten von mechanisierten
Verbänden stark einschränkt ist weitere
300 km lang er muss eigentlich ebenfalls
gesichert werden wenn auch nicht mehr so
stark nach dem Dammbruch bei novakarovka
im Nordosten und Norden wo die Ukraine
direkt an Russland grenzt kommen jedoch
weitere 600 km hinzu allein wenn die
russische Militärführung aber derzeit
versucht die 600 km lange aktive Front
und in erster mit etwa 200.000 Mann
abzusichern bedeutet dies dass die
durchschnittlich Konzentration der
russischen Kräfte und Ressourcen pro
Kilometer Front relativ gering ist
nämlich nur 250 bis 300 Mann also viel
zu wenig für eine wirksame Verteidigung
gegen massierte gepanzerte mobile
Kampfverbände damit ihr euch ein Bild
machen könnt über welche Dimension wir
hier reden die Westfront im Ersten
Weltkrieg die sich von der Nordseeküste
Belgiens bis zur Schweizer Grenze
erstreckte war 700 Kilometer lang das
deutsche Heer hatte zu ihrer
Verteidigung 1,5 Millionen Soldaten
stationiert also im Vergleich zu den
Russen heute rund 9 mal mehr pro
Kilometer Frontlinie und damals hatten
sie es nicht mit schnellen mobilen
gepanzerten Kampfverbänden zu tun aber
das man lieben Zuschauer ist noch nicht
alles eine Großteil der russischen
Truppen wird auch hinter der Front
benötigt um z.B die vor sind blutige
russische Logistik sicher zu stellen
darüber dass die russische Armee keine
Paletten und Gabelstapler erkennt und
Artillerie Munition immer noch einzeln
behandelt haben wir bereits in einem
früheren Video gelacht aber im Ernst
aufgrund der geringen Produkte und
Effizienz der russischen Streitkräfte
werden real nicht mehr als 100 bis 150
Mann pro Kilometer an der kontaktlinie
in direkten verfügbar sein das Ziel
besteht darin die andere Seite an Dinge
glauben zu lassen die nicht eintreten
werden den Abschnitten in denen derzeit
keine aktiven Kampfhandlungen
stattfinden wird die Fronten noch dünner
besetzt sein und in einigen Abschnitten
wird die Front vielleicht gar nicht
existiert natürlich könnte genau dies am
Ende den Ukraine den entscheidenden
Vorteil verschaffen
mehr noch die Ukraine bereiten den Boden
für ihren Befreiungsschlag mindestens
seit Anfang 2023 vor und ich meine dabei
nicht nur die Vorbereitung der Truppen
fast das gesamte Jahr 2023 hindurch
haben die Ukraine täglich russische
logistikeinrichtungen in Gebieten
angegriffen die weit von der Front
entfernt sind und zwar mit Heimat und
GLS die eine Reichweite von bis zu 150
km haben und seit kurzem auch mit Storm
Raketen die vom Vereinigten Königreich
geliefert worden in einigen Fällen
wurden auch kleine Kamikaze Drohnen
eingesetzt bei all diesen Angriffen
haben die Ukrainer zahlreiche russische
Treibstoff und Munitionsdepots Kommando
Posten Kaserne und Verwaltungsgebäude
zerstört einige davon sogar auf dem
Territorium der Russischen Föderation
selbst
okay bedeutet dies nun das alles bereit
ist reicht es aus die zugesagten Waffen
zu erhalten und dann einige wichtige
Ziele anzugreifen nein natürlich nicht
es gibt viele andere Faktoren die wir
berücksichtigen müssen von der Logistik
die wir bereits erwähnt haben bis zu
operativen Situation eine Armee wieder
ukrainischen die eine schreckliche
Wirkung erlitten hat aus diesem Grund
musste Aktionsplan all diese Aspekte
berücksichtigen also sehen wir uns
diesen doch mal an und lasst uns dabei
auch gleich klären wie stark selenskys
Armee wirklich ist wird sie die Russen
schlagen können
[Musik]
die große Inventur
wir haben es bereits eingangs erwähnt
falls die Ukraine wirklich nur über jene
lächerlichen 12 mechanisierten Brigaden
verfügen sollte von denen in den
angeblichen Pentagon legs die Rede ist
wäre es für Kiel viel besser gar keine
offensiv-operation anzustreben und
lieber schön in der strategischen
Defensive zu bleiben denn 12 Brigaden
das sind nur 60 bis 70.000 Soldaten und
auch wenn eine relativ kleine aber
hochmotivierte gut geführte gut
ausgebildet und modern ausgerüstete
Armee in der Lage wäre einen viel
größeren Gegner auf dem Schlachtfeld in
einem symmetrischen Manöver Krieg zu
besiegen wird sie nicht mehr in der Lage
sein das besetzte Gebiet und die neu
entstandene Fronten lange zu
kontrollieren 12 mechanisierte Brigaden
Stellen in den Maßstäben des
endmilitarisierten Westeuropa vielleicht
eine große militärische Streitkraft darf
aber sie reichen eben nicht aus um die
Russen erfolgreich anzugreifen und
anschließend die lange Grenze zu
Russland zu sichern ja und dann dieser
Stelle können wir es euch ja endlich
verraten die Pentagon legs sind voller
Bullshit wieso das wäre ein Thema für
ein ganz anderes Video an dieser Stelle
interessiert uns nur eines die Tatsache
dass die ukrainische Armee heute eine
militärische Kraft ist die in Europa
ihresgleichen sucht denn Kiew verfügt
ganz offensichtlich über viel mehr viel
viel mehr
[Musik]
schon vor dem Krieg hatte die Ukraine
mindestens 11 aktive mechanisierte
Brigaden vier motorisierte Brigaden 2
gebirgsjägerbrigaden und zwei
panzergregaten als Reserve verfügte sie
darüber hinaus über 5 mechanisierte
Brigaden vier panzerbrigaden und eine
motorisierte Brigade rechnen muss man
auch fünf luftland und zwei
marinebrigaden wenn man das alles
zusammenzählt kommt man auf 36
Formationen im brigadenstärke wie gesagt
vor Kriegsausbruch nun haben die
ukrainische Streitkräfte im Laufe des
mehr als einjährigen Krieges natürlich
erhebliche Verluste erleben
maximalschätzung gehen von bis zu 120
getöteten Verwundeten außer Gefecht
gesetzten Gefangenen und vermissten
Soldaten aus die Frage ist daher in wie
weit konnten diese ersetzt werden nun
wie über öffentlich zugängliche Quellen
ersichtlich wird und was selbst
ukrainische Behörden wiederholt
halboffiziell bestätigt haben hat die
Ukraine in der Tat zwischen 700.000 und
einer Millionen Menschen in mehreren
mobilisierungswellen in den Medien
gebracht dies ist eine Zahl die durchaus
im Rahmen der Möglichkeiten einer Nation
mit 40 Millionen Einwohnern liegt die um
ihr Überleben
auch aus dem Jahrbuch military Balance
2022 des Stockholm international Peace
Research Institute standen Kiew vor dem
Krieg schon 900.000 trefferisten zur
Verfügung
so und nun lasst uns rechnen 120.000 der
mobilisierten Ukraine wurden zu
Ersetzung der Verluste in bestehenden
Brigaden und weitere 60.000 zur
Auffüllung von Reserveeinheiten
eingesetzt die vor dem Krieg nicht
annähernd ihre volle Stärke erreicht
hatten außerdem ging wohl weitere
120.000 Wehrpflichtige zur
Territorialverteidigung über die wir ein
eigenes Video gedreht haben ich werde es
euch verlinken weitere 250.000 wurden
den Hilfstruppen zugewiesen da es sich
um Rekruten mit schlechterer
gesundheitlicher Qualifikation und in
fortgeschrittenem Alter handelt bleiben
also immer noch etwa 300.000 bis 400.000
wirklich wichtiger und das meine Lieben
Zuschauer ist ein ausreichendes
Reservoir und viele Brigaden über das
Vorkriegsniveau hinaus aufzubauen selbst
wenn die bisherigen Verluste der Ukraine
die aller pessimistischsten Schätzungen
um das doppelt übersteigen würden also
bei 250.000 legen und unter
Berücksichtigung des Problems
angemessene Ausbildungskapazitäten
verfügt die Ukraine also über genügend
Personal um Verluste zu ersetzen und
viele weitere Einheiten aufzubauen offen
zugänglichen Quellen zu Folge hat jetzt
seit dem Beginn der russischen Invasion
im Februar 2022 damit begonnen
mindestens 15 neue manöver-verbände zu
bilden im April diesen Jahres wurde der
Aufbau neuer Kampfbrigaden angekündigt
in den 40.000 stark motivierte Soldaten
mit besonders patriotischer Gesinnung
dienen sollen darüber hinaus soll die
Nationalgarde 6 Brigaden bilden und die
Polizei und ein Grenzschutz jeweils
einer hinzukommen mindestens 12 neue
mechanisierte Brigaden drei Feldjäger
Brigaden und acht stoßtruppenformationen
und dann wird dies alles zusammenzählen
verfügt das ukrainische Kommando über
etwa 60 Mal never Brigaden sofort
einsatzfähig durften davon Experten
zufolge etwa 30 bis 35 sein also mehr
als die Hälfte na das klingt doch schon
etwas besser als die 12 Brigaden aus dem
Pentagon liegt ihr seht also schon daran
dass man wirklich jede geliebte
Information an hat viele andere Quellen
auf ihre Plausibilität verifizieren
sollte aber warte wir sind nämlich noch
lange nicht fertig da wären nämlich noch
mindestens 25 Brigaden der territorial
Verteidigung die ebenfalls weit in
motorisiert sind und achtjährigen der
Artillerie und Rake Zielgruppen die
Summe aller Einheiten in brigadenstärke
einschließlich Luftverteidigung
Luftwaffe Logistik und
Trainingseinheiten sollte so bereits
heute über 100 liegen Tendenz steigend
wir reden hier also über mehr als eine
halbe Million einsatzbereiter Truppen
auf ukrainischer Seite den etwa 200 bis
350.000 Russen gegenüberstehen und trotz
aller Herausforderungen welche die
Ausbildung Vorbereitung und Koordination
100.000 Soldaten relativ kurzer Zeit
darstellt dürfte der Ausbildungsstand
der ukrainischen Streitkräfte wesentlich
höher liegen als auf russischer Seite
denn die russische Armee befindet sich
in einer Situation die sie nie erwartet
hat Putin führt in der Ukraine einen
Krieg mit völlig unrealistischen Zielen
niemand konnte seine Bemühungen um eine
Entnazifizierung und endmilitarisierung
der Ukraine Ärztin seinen Truppen ist es
aber auch nicht gelungen seiner
reduzierten Ziele aus dem Herbst 2020 zu
erfüllen die Einnahme des don-bas bis
März 2023 stattdessen erlebte die einst
als zweitstärkste Streit Macht der Welt
geltende Armee eine Demütigung und
Zermürbung nach der anderen und zwar
durch die Streitkräfte eines viel
kleineren Landes das erstens ums
Überleben kämpft und zweitens ein viel
konkreteres Ziel verfolgt nämlich die
Rückeroberung seines Territoriums in den
Grenzen von 1991 die russischen Verluste
an Soldaten Unteroffizieren Ausbildern
Panzern gepanzerten Transportfahrzeugen
und sogar Hubschraubern Flugzeugen und
generieren waren bisher exorbitant viel
mehr als man in Moskau jemals geschätzt
hätte und während all dessen erhielten
die Ukraine entgegenzug große Mengen an
militärischer Ausrüstung während z.B
2020 noch alte T-72 geliefert wurden
treffen 2023 bereits moderne westliche
Panzer ein daneben bekam sie auch andere
gepanzerte Fahrzeuge wie den bradleader
über starke panzerabwehrfähigkeiten
verfügt oder den geparkt zur Luftabwehr
bedenkt bitte dass Sie sich bei diesen
Waffen auch wenn sie nicht in großer
Zahl eintreffen nicht mehr um
ausgemusterte Exemplare aus veralteten
Beständen handelt sondern um
Waffensysteme die von den Armenien der
USA und Europas selbst eingesetzt werden
wenn sie in einen Krieg eintreten würden
es handelt sich um einen riesigen
Katalog von Panzerhaubitzen NATO
Standardmunition
langstreckenluftbodenraketen wie der
britischen Storm Shadow und sogar die
Sparrow Bodenluft Raketen um russische
Marschflugkörper und Kampfflugzeuge
abzuschießen und wie wir schon vor
langer Zeit vorhergesagt haben ist es
schließlich auch noch hierzu gekommen
die Verbündeten der Ukraine könnten 50
F16 liefern das ist genau die Zahl an
F16 die die Ukraine jetzt braucht aber
die Frage ist wie die Ukraine nun all
diese Gerätschaft verwenden werden
können übrigens 16 werden mit dem nicht
ein spezielles Video hier auf
visualpolitik veröffentlichen also
vergesst bitte nicht den Kanal zu
abonnieren unbedingt mit Glöckchen denn
ohne Glöckchen ignorierte Youtube
Algorithmus sowieso welche Kanäle ihr
abonniert habt oder nicht nehmt also
euer See Verhalten selbst in die Hand
und aktiviert bitte das Glöckchen euer
Gehirn wird es euch danken und wir
ebenso
aber zurück zum Thema es ist logisch
dass wir diesen Video nicht die wirklich
konkreten Pläne der Offensive erraten
können aber anhand viele offener Quellen
Hintergrundinformationen der Waffen die
die Ukraine hält und der aktuellen Lage
an der Front können wir uns eine recht
klare Vorstellung davon machen wie diese
Aktion ablaufen könnte wie ihr vorhin
anhand unserer Berechnungen gesehen habt
verfügt das ukrainische Oberkommando
über genügend Kräfte und Ressourcen zu
Durchführung Offensive Operation die die
russischen Verteidigungsstellungen im
Süden und Osten der Ukraine überbinden
und zerstören können nach und nach kann
Kiew alle Manöver Brigaden einbringen
während sie auf volle Stärke aufgefüllt
werden wobei die Einheiten anfordern um
Verluste zu ersetzen die Frage auf
russischer Seite wird sein wie man den
daraus erfolgenden Verschleiß zu
ersetzen gedenkt damit die eigene Frauen
die ja die eigene Armee nicht
zusammenbrechen nötig wäre mindestens
eine große mobil machen die jedoch viel
besser und professioneller ablaufen
müsste als die bisherige und davon ist
aufgrund der allgemeinen Erschöpfung der
organisatorischen und
ausrüstungstechnischen Ressourcen Moskau
nur gefährlich auszugehen vor allem
nicht in der nun verbleibenden Zeit das
opportunitätsfenster für die ukrainische
Führung öffnet sich daher gerade jetzt
und wird bis Mitte Oktober offen bleiben
bevor wieder die rasputita die
schlammzeit einsetzt lasst uns nun also
die Optionen Kiese erörtern die auf
Einschätzung von Militärexperten und
Geheimdienst berichten beruhen viele
Analysten weisen daraufhin dass die
gegen Offensive höchstwahrscheinlich an
einem von den großen stark befestigten
Punkt ansetzen wird um zu versuchen die
Front in zwei Teile aufzuspalten es ist
zum Beispiel denkbar dass die Ukrainer
mit ihren Leopard Panzern und ihren
westlichen Truppentransportern
versuchten könnten die russischen
Verteidigungsanlagen in der Nähe von
mellito polwert jansk und sogar Mario
putze durchbrechen anstatt sich die
bisher auf den doll was zu konzentrieren
diese Angriff könnte also in der oblass
saporicia beginnen allerdings eben
weiter im Osten nicht in denen nach der
Sprengung des departams überfluteten
Gebieten tatsächlich sind die großen
selbst über diese ukrainische Option
stark besorgt seht euch mal folgendes an
27 April 2023 Russland zieht sich zurück
während sich die Ukraine auf einen
Angriff vorbereitet die russischen
Panzerabwehr greben in der Nähe der
ukrainischen Stadt Polo hier in Südosten
des Landes erstrecken sich über 30 km
dahinter befinden sich rein von
betonbarrikaden mit drachenzähnen weiter
hinten befinden sich verteidigungsgräben
in denen die russischen Truppen
positioniert werden ja es handelt sich
um eine Reihe von Befestigungsanlagen
die Russland in den letzten Monaten vor
allem in der Südukraine vorbereitet hat
seht euch mal diese Karte an
alle Punkte die auf dem Bildschirm sieht
sind russische Befestigungen die bereits
identifiziert werden konnten sagen wir
einfach die Russen sehen Sie sich
absolut bewusst dass ihr größter
Albtraum gerade ein ukrainischer
Durchbruch der Front im Gebiet von
mellitopol Bert jansk und Mario Puls
sein könnte und deshalb haben sie alles
getan um diesen Raum mit Hindernissen
Minen und Gräben zu füllen dazu gehören
auch die berühmten Drachenzähne
diejenigen unter euch die mal Call of
Duty gespielt haben wissen sicher was
damit gemeint ist und wir sprechen hier
über die ersten Teile der spielerserie
die noch im Zweiten Weltkrieg spielte
tja tatsache ist dass wir hier wirklich
über gängige Verteidigungsstrategien aus
dem Zweiten Weltkrieg sprechen die jetzt
auf russische Seite ein come back
erleben allerdings handelt es sich bei
den russischen drachenzähnen eher um die
wischversion echter Verteidigungsanlagen
wieder einmal ist wohl der größte Teil
des Budgets nicht in den Beton an der
Front sondern in denen der russischen
Bonzen Willen geflossen echte wirksame
drachenzahnpanzer Hindernisse sind
nämlich viel größer in ein langes festes
Betonfundament gegossen und mit jeder
Menge Stahlstreben gesteckt all diese
Eigenschaften fehlen den russischen
Drachen sehen seht euch zum Beispiel mal
an wie Drachenzähne aussehen die in
Südkorea an der Grenze zu Nordkorea
stehen
das Fazit für die Streitkräfte der
Ukraine mit ihrer präzisen Artillerie
und dem großen modernen und
leistungsfähigen Panzern aus den besten
Stellen die russischen möchtegern
Drachenzähne bestenfalls ein Hindernis
darf für ein bis zwei Minuten aber in
diesen Fällen werden normalerweise
sowieso Pionierdienst als Vorauskommando
eingesetzt sobald das Gelände mit
Artillerie gesichert ist übernehmen
diese Teams so wichtige Aufgaben wie das
Räumen von Minenfeldern das Öffnen von
Straßen den Bau von Brücken und ja auch
das Zerstören von drachenzähnen und
Schützengräben eine solche
spezialisation und Ausrüstung ist für
jede militärische Offensive unerlässlich
weshalb die modernsten westlichen Armeen
ihr enorme Bedeutung bei Messen
natürlich ist es streng geheim in wie
weit die Ukraine über solche Kurs mit
ausrechnen Mitteln und Vorbereitung
verfügt und zwar so geheim das ist nie
und nimmer im E-Mail Verteiler eines
zweiundzwanzigjährigen Minecraft
Spielers und Angehörigen der Message ist
luftnation mit niedrigsten dies gerade
auftauchen würde
[Musik]
mit anderen Worten all diese
Befestigungen werden für die Ukraine
kein echtes Hindernis darstellen sondern
eher eine Verzögerung eine Verzögerung
die selenskys Truppen etwas länger in
feinem Gebiet exponiert lassen könnte
die russischen zertifikationsanlagen
wenn man sie denn überhaupt so nennen
kann können also die Verluste der
ukrainischen Streitkräfte erhöhen sind
jedoch kaum dazu geeignet deren
tatsächliche Schlagkraft zu schwächen
aber natürlich behauptet niemand dass
die gegen Offensive ein Kinderspiel
werden würde und dies erklärt auch warum
die Vorbereitungen so lange gedauert
haben trotzdem muss man sich im Klaren
darüber sein dass es eben an dieser
Stelle für die Ukraine besonders
schwierig wird vorzustoßen viel
schwieriger als an anderen Stellen warum
also weisen so viele müssten darauf hin
dass das Hauptziel der Ukraine darin
bestehen könnte zu versuchen die
russischen Linien genau hier
durchzubrechen nur in wesentlichen aus
einem Grund der Grimm
die Ukraine könnte die kürzlich
erhaltenen schweren Waffen des bestens
nutzen um die russische Front in zwei
Teile aufzubrechen und so die Krim vom
Don Bass zu trennen auf diese Weise wäre
einer der russische nachschubbehindert
und andererseits die Krim ungeschützt
darüber hinaus würden Gebietsgewinne in
den Gebieten saporisha und Person ist
den Ukrainern ermöglichen die Creme
Brücke die die Halbinsel über die Straße
von Kersch mit Russland verbindet in
Reichweite reguläre Artillerie zu
bringen das heißt sie wären für die
Kontrolle der Brücke nicht auf die
kostbaren Präzisionswaffen wie heilmaß
und Storm Shadow angewiesen die
Zerstörung dieser Brücke und ein
hypothetischer Bruch der russischen
Front würde die Creme in eine äußerst
verwundbare Lage bringen was die Russen
zu Verhandlungen zwingen könnte
Verhandlungen die dann zu einem
vollständigen Rückzug aus der Ukraine
führen könnten oder zu einem teilweisen
Rückzug mit Ausnahme der Krim selbst
jeder letztendlich eben als russisch
anerkannt werden könnte
in Frage kommen auch mögliche gegen
offensiven bei wurde da in Richtung des
logistischen drehkretes zum also schon
mehr dort könnte man erklären müsste
sich aber erneut der russischen
Luftwaffe stellen weitere Stoßrichtungen
wären bei bachmut das aber eher ein
politisches als ein strategisches Ziel
darstellt oder bei swato wer im Norden
der Region du kannst im Wald könnten die
Ukraine die russischen Truppen bis an
die russische Grenze zurückgetragen wird
[Musik]
dann würden sie aber nicht nur ihre
eigene Front verlängern sondern wären
auch der Gefahr eines Angriffs vom Süden
her aus dem besetzten Gebiet der Region
Johannes und von Norden aus Russland
ausgesetzt und aus all diesen Gründen
gilt einen Gegenoffensive in der Region
saporesia als die wahrscheinlichste
Variante sie könnte der ukrainischen
Armee gleich mehrere Vorteile bringen
diese würde nicht nur die Kontrolle über
das Atomkraftwerk zurückgewinnen sondern
auch wenn ihre Truppen das also schon
mehr erreichen Russland Landverbindung
zu halten Insel Creme abschneiden und
die Truppen dort isolieren außerdem wäre
in einem solchen Fall wie gesagt fast
das gesamte Gebiet der Grimm in
Reichweite der ukrainischen Artillerie
die Nachteile dieser Option sind wie
gesagt die starken russischen
Verteidigungslinien und das offene
Gelände das für Bodentruppen im Kampf
gegen einen Feind mit Luft Überlegenheit
problematisch ist außerdem besteht das
Risiko dass die Russen das Atomkraftwerk
bei saporisch an die Luft jagen so wie
bereits den Staudamm bei novakarovk aber
dazu später mehr an dieser Stelle ist es
wichtig sich zu vergegenwärtigen dass
wir hier noch immer über einen
knallharten blutigen und brutalen Krieg
sprechen wir sollten uns dich nichts
vormachen sollten diese oder ähnliche
Pläne während der gegen Offensive
umgesetzt werden ist es durchaus möglich
dass die Kosten für die Ukraine in die
Tausende oder gar 10.000 von Opfern
gehen könnten die Frage ist ob es eine
Möglichkeit gibt einen neuen Aderlass
neue bachmuts an einer viel größeren
Front zu vermeiden nun ja diese
Möglichkeit gibt es sicherlich eine
Möglichkeit wäre nämlich die Lieferung
das seit langem erwarteten taktischen
raketensystems der USA in Kiew dieses
ist in der Lage Ziele in einer
Entfernung von bis zu 300 Kilometern
präzise zu treffen dennoch scheint
Washington zumindest im Moment nicht
bereit zu sein dieses System in
ukrainische Hände zu geben und die Frage
ist warum warum
Opfern die Amis lieber tausende von
Ukraine an anstatt dieses Systeme zu
liefern nun die Antwort darauf ist viel
bedeutender als dies auf den ersten
Blick aussehen mag schnallt Euch jetzt
lieber noch mal richtig gut an
[Musik]
das letzte Ast im Ärmeln
die Vereinigten Staaten sind bei der
westlichen verteidigungshilfe für die
Ukraine das mit Abstand größte Geberland
bis heute haben die US-Steuerzahler seit
Beginn der Invasion fast 40 Milliarden
Dollar für Militärhilfe an die Ukraine
ausgegeben um dies in die richtige
Perspektive zu rücken wir sprechen von
3,5 Millionen Dollar pro Stunde eine
gigantische Menge an Ressourcen mit
denen sich eine riesiger Katalog
gelieferter Waffen angefühlt hat aber
Tatsache ist das ist eine Waffe gibt die
weiterhin unerreichbar bleibt das
taktische Raketensystem der US-Armee
washington will zumindest im Augenblick
nichts von der Lieferung dieser Raketen
wissen obwohl die Ukraine sie schon seit
einem Jahr fortan warum sind die Amis
aber so extrem zögerlich wenn es gerade
um diese Waffe geht warum wollen sie sie
nicht an die Ukraine aushändigen nun im
Wesentlichen um einen weiteren
Eskalation des Konflikt zu vermeiden das
ist die wichtigste Erklärung aber wie um
alles in der Welt könnten diese Raketen
einen Konfl in dem es bereits zu
bodenangriffen auf russisches
Territorium gekommen ist noch weiter
eskalieren nun einige einflussreiche
Personen im Weißen Haus und den Pentagon
glauben dass die Ukraine dieser Raketen
notfalls gegen russisches Territorium
einsetzen könnte und dies würde dann zur
gefürchteten nuklearen Eskalation führen
diese Möglichkeit will Washington unter
keinen Umständen riskieren bevor die USA
der Ukraine also sowohl die Möglichkeit
als auch die Erlaubnis geben mit ihren
Waffen Direktorium der Russischen
Föderation anzugreifen wollen Sie zu
100% sicherstellen dass ein atomarer
Gegenschlag zu wahnsinnig und
verzweifelt und kontraproduktiv diese
auch wäre ausgeschlossen bzw
neutralisiert werden kann wir haben über
dieses Vorhaben schon vor kurzem ein
Video gedreht ich werde es euch
verlinken und ja ich weiß was viele von
euch die sich gut in der Materie
auskennen jetzt denken die Ukraine
verfügt ja bereits über die britischen
Raketen die Ziele in mehr als 250 km
Entfernung erreichen mit ihnen kann sie
doch auch russisches Territorium
angreifen nun ja der Haken an der ganzen
Geschichte ist hier hat die storm aber
gleichzeitig hat es sie auch nicht der
Unterschied besteht nämlich darin dass
das US-System von mobilen
Abschussvorrichtungen aus eingesetzt
werden kann die sich leicht in jedem
Winkel verstecken lassen während die
Storm shadow-ausrüstung viel
schwerfälliger und riskanter ist da sie
nur von Flugzeugen aus eingesetzt werden
kann wie von André sagordnung den
ehemaligen Verteidigungsminister der
Ukraine bestätigt könnten die Ukraine
mit Hilfe der us-landstrecke Raketen
unter überlegenen amerikanischen
Aufklärung die meisten russischen
Kommando posten und Waffen Depot sicher
und präzise ausschalten und nicht nur
das diese Raketen könnten sogar die
Verteidigungsanlagen auf der land-engel
der Krim oder die Brücke zerstören die
diese Region über die Straße von
Russland verbindet es handelt sich um
Raketen die auch schwer abzufangen
werden da sie sich mit dreifacher
Schallgeschwindigkeit fortbewegen was
sie zu einem Albtraum für die Russen
machen könnte wie bereits gesagt haben
wir in einem früheren Video ausführlich
erläutert wie die USA nach Wegen suchen
die atomare Bedrohung aus Russland
neutralisieren einige gute Ansätze haben
sie bereits gefunden allerdings reichen
nach Ansicht der pentagonstrategen noch
nicht aus um vollkommene Sicherheit zu
gewährleisten und diese ist in der
nuklearen Frage eben unbedingt notwendig
und so lange muss eben das alte
salami-spiel gespielt und langsam
scheibchenweise eskaliert werden die
Russen werden Stück für Stück daran
gewöhnt dass die Ukraine immer
mächtigere Waffen bekommt denn alles auf
einmal wäre nicht nur logistisch
problematisch es wäre auch psychologisch
und klug gegenüber einem
psychopathischen Feind dass dieser
wirklich zu jeder schon tatsächlich ist
ohne Rücksicht auf die Zivilbevölkerung
und sogar eigenes Soldaten wenn er nur
den Mittel dazu hat zeigt die Sprengung
des kachowa Staudamms es ist etwas was
ich einreit in viele viele der
Verbrechen die wir in der Ukraine
gesehen haben die von russischen
Soldaten ausgegangen sind es gehört zu
einer Kriegsführung die auch immer
zivile Ziele Städte doch vor
Krankenhäuser Schule Infrastrukturen
angegriffen hat was mit einer
militärischen Kriegsführung der erstmal
gar nicht verbunden wäre deshalb ist es
etwas was eine neue Dimension hat aber
zur Art und Weise passt wie bisschen
diesen Krieg führt Olaf Scholz deutscher
Bundeskanzler Russland überschreitet
immer mehr Grenzen seiner Aggression der
Anschlag auf den novakhovka Damen mitten
in den bewohnten Gebiet ist mit dem
Einsatz von Massenvernichtungswaffen
gegen zivilistenvergleichbar diese
Brutalität wird verurteilt und bestraft
werden Jan Lebowski Außenminister
Tschechiens es dürfte klar sein dass wir
hier eine der kritischsten Momente
dieses Krieges erleben werden aber
Präsident Salewski hat bereits betont
dass auch die Zerstörung des novakaros
kardamts und die dadurch ausgelöstete
flugkatastrophe nichts an seinen
offensivplänen ändern werden und bei der
Frage wer für den Dammbruch
verantwortlich ist müssen drei klare
Fakten bedacht werden erstens dass dies
nicht das erste Mal war dass die Russen
im Rahmen ihrer Kriegsführung einen Damm
springen zweitens das die russischen
Besatzer die Stausee bereits seit Wochen
weit über seinen sicheren Wasserpegel
angefühlt haben tja fast so als hätten
sie tatsächlich geplant im Falle einer
Sprengung den angerichteten Schaden zu
maximieren mehr noch kurz vor der
Zerstörung des Namens hat Russland
Gesetz verabschiedet dass die Betreiber
von Wasseranlagen von jeglicher Haftung
befreit und Untersuchungen von Unfällen
verhindert bis zum 1 Januar 2028 wird
die technische Untersuchung von Unfällen
in gefährlichen Produktionsanlagen und
von Unfällen in Wasserbauwerken die sich
infolge von militärischen Aktionen
Sabotage und terroristischen Handlungen
ereignet haben nicht durchgeführt
regierungs-föderation Nummer 873 von 30
mai 2023 offenbar wurden die russischen
Behörden und Betreiber der Staudamms vom
Militär vorab über die sprengen
informiert so dass Sie schnell einen
Erlass auf den Weg brachten der sie aus
der Haftung nimmt unglaublich aber wahr
und drittens hatte die Ukraine eben wie
gesagt keinen physischen Zugang zur
Talsperre sie wird nach wie vor von
russischen Truppen kontrolliert und das
meine Lieben Zuschauer macht die Sache
dann ziemlich eindeutig denn so ein
Damen wird er in Novak auch gar ist von
außen verdammt schwer zu springen der
Grund seine Konstruktion ist ähnlich wie
die von Kernkraftwerken speziell darauf
ausgerichtet darauf Angriffen mit
Sprengstoff Flugzeugabstürzen und auch
militärischen Angriffen mit Artillerie
oder Raketen standzuhalten bei seiner
Errichtung wurden erhebliche
Sicherheitsmargen eingeplant so dass es
äußerst schwierig wäre ihn von außen zu
zerstören gemäß einige Experten würde
dies spezialbomben oder sogar taktische
Atomwaffen erfordern über die die
Ukraine nun mal nicht verfügt wenn man
die durch Zugang zur dann Infrastruktur
hat wie eben das russische Militär kann
man ihn von innen springen selbst
hierfür sind dutzende Tonnen von
Sprengstoff notwendig und diese müssen
noch an den richtigen Stellen angebracht
werden nun ja und genau das haben die
Russen bereits im April letzten Jahres
getan so für den Fall der Fälle
sozusagen okay jetzt wo wir die
Verantwortlichkeit geklärt hätten
sollten wir noch der Frage nachgehen was
Russland mit der Sprengung eigentlich
bezwingen könnte die Zerstörung des
Kaufhof kardamt hätte für Russland einen
gewissen militärischen Nutzen die
Überflutung und die Bindung von
Ressourcen zur Eindämmung der
humanitären Katastrophe könnte die
ukrainische gegen Offensive
möglicherweise mal langsam aber eben nur
minimal wie gesagt ist es für die
Ukrainer strategisch viel interessanter
an anderen Stellen vorzustoßen als im
jetzigen Überschwemmungsgebiet dieses
war auch vorher nur mit ausreichend
ausgerüsteten amphibischen Verbänden
passierbar und mit diesen ist die
Ukraine sowieso nicht gut ausgerüstet
zumindest weisen die westlichen
Lieferungen an schweren
manöverfahrzeugen nicht darauf hin und
wenn wir uns die weiteren Folgen der
dammsprengung ansehen wird es noch
schwerer ein klares Motiv der Russen zu
finden ganz im Gegenteil denn nachdem
sie den kaufvergaben in die Luft gejagt
haben ist die Frage der Wasserversorgung
der Creme einfach alle mal erledigt es
wird nicht möglich sein die Versorgung
innerhalb der nächsten fünf bis sieben
Jahre wiederherzustellen wenn Russland
die Creme wirklich behalten wollen wäre
es überhaupt nicht in seinem Interesse
den Kaufhof Stausee trocken zu leben
denn diese dient über einen Kanalsystem
also Wasserquelle für die Landwirtschaft
in relativ trockenen Süden der Ukraine
und auf der Krim also all diese Gebiete
die Russland mittlerweile per
einseitigen Dekret anikidiert hatte für
diese Gebiete ist er auch als
Trinkwasserquelle enorm wichtig im Jahr
2014 reagierten die Ukraine auf die
Besetzung der Krim durch Russland ja
indem sie den Durchfluss des Kanals
blockierten und die Halbinsel ohne
Wasser zurückließen zum Vergleich noch
2013 wurden anderthalb Millionen
Kubikmeter Wasser aus dem nordgrim Kanal
entnommen was etwa 85% des gesamten
Trink und bewässerungswasser entspricht
von diesen wichtigen Quellen
abgestritten begann damals für die Creme
sehr schwere Zeiten die Wasserknappheit
hat die lokale Landwirtschaft Industrie
und Bevölkerung schwer getroffen und
auch wenn die Wasserversorgung der
Landwirte Vorrang vor den Haushalten
bekam musste man den Anbau Wasser
intensiver Kulturen komplett verbieten
die Trinkwasserversorgung wurde
hauptsächlich durch Tankwagen
sichergestellt und genau aus diesem
Gründen war die Besetzung der Oblast
Person und ihre Wasseranlagen eines der
ersten Ziele der russischen Aggressionen
im ersten Monat des Krieges im Februar
2020 außerdem versorgt der kakowski
Kanal auch das besetzte Berg und die
meisten Dörfer in der Region saporea mit
Wasser hinzu kommt das durch den Bruch
des Darms der bis zu 18 Kubikkilometer
Wasser erfasst auch das linke dir
perufer unter russischer Besatzung
überflutet wird das linke also östliche
Ufer in der oblass her sondern wird
immer stärker betroffen sein weil es
tiefer liegt als das rechte westliche
Ufer russische Truppen werden von den
Fluten mitgerissen als der Damm am
Dienstag brach konnte niemand auf der
russischen Seite entkommen sagte
Hauptmann andres nie ein offizierter
ukrainischen Streitkräfte gegenüber CNN
alle Regimenter die die Russen auf
dieser Seite hatten wurden überflutet er
sagte dass viele russische Soldaten in
den Chaos getötet oder verwundet worden
doch die folgende Überflutung für die
Region gehen weit über den Faktor Wasser
hinaus es könnte Jahrzehnte dauern bis
die Verheerungen durch den Kauf auf
verdamm Bruch beseitigt sind es ist
offensichtlich dass dieser Dammbruch
langfristig weitreichende negative
ökologische und umweltpolitische Folgen
nicht nur für die Ukraine sondern auch
für die Nachbarländer und Regionen haben
wird in den Trümmern die das Wasser mit
sich reißt befinden sich Zehntausende
von Minen die nun wahllos in Städten
Dörfern und Ackerland Fluss abwärts
verteilt werden dies bedeutet das
Zivilisten viele Kilometer vom
Konfliktgebiet entfernt in die Luft
gesprengt werden können viele Jahre nach
den Krieg das ökologische Traum einer
solchen Überschwemmung mit Wasser und
Schlamm hat die Landschaft in einem
Augenblick verändert und Inseln und
Feuchtgebiete ausgelöscht es könnte
Jahre wenn ich Jahrzehnte dauern bis ich
die Fauna und Flora wieder erholt hat
der ukrainische Präsident wurde selenski
sprach von der größten von Menschen
verursachten Umweltkatastrophe in Europa
seit Jahrzehnten darüber hinaus werden
die schwarzen armenierter Dell paar von
einer ölpestheim gesucht denn die
Wassermassen haben 150 Tonnen Motoröl
mit sich gerissen der bei vielen großen
beliebte kriegen Urlaub dürfte in
verseuchtes Wasserfallen es sieht also
ganz so aus als hätten sich die Russen
mit der dammsprengungen erster Linie
auch selbst in den Fuß geschossen die
Frage ist also wieso nun eine Antwort
könnte sein es war eine verzweifelte
Kurzschlusshandlung man musste
angesichts des Unheils das mit der
Gegend offensiver auf einen zu sollte
einfach nichts anderes mehr anzurichten
eine andere Antwort ist jedoch logischer
und leider gruseliger enthält
gleichzeitig aber auch einen Funken
Hoffnung
das esse ich nämlich um eine Taktik
handelt die den Terror gegen die
Bevölkerung mit der Strategie der
verbrannten Erde verbindet da man sich
in Moskau immer mehr im Klaren darüber
ist dass der Krieg mit gängigen
militärischen Mitteln nicht mehr zu
gewinnen ist will man es allen noch mal
zeigen irgendwie er liegt man dort noch
immer der Illusion die ukrainische
Bevölkerung ließe sich durch
terroreinschüchtern tja und wenn nicht
naja dann sind die besetzten Gebiete
inklusive Krim sowieso verloren und wenn
sie Russland nicht haben kann soll sie
keiner haben können es wird verbrannte
Erde hinterlassen wie gesagt birgt diese
Erklärung ein Hoffnung in sich wenn sie
impliziert dass die Russen mit ihrer
Niederlage oder Befreiung der besetzten
Gebiete rechnen andererseits fließt sie
natürlich jede Menge Horror ein denn
dann stellt sich die Frage wie weit sie
noch gehen werden vor allem weil sie
offenbar auch bereit sind die eigene
Bevölkerung und eigene Soldaten auf dem
Altar der Rache zu opfern schließlich
haben sie ja nicht nur den Kauf auf
verstaut sondern auch das Kernkraftwerk
in SAP ich meine wie wahnsinnig
skrupellos und menschenverachten muss
man sein um ein Atomkraftwerk zu
vermieden allein die Vorbereitung dieser
Tat stellt einen Zivilisationsbruch da
mit dem Russland in seiner heutigen Form
jegliche Existenzberechtigung verloren
hat findet ihr dass ich das zu hart
formuliert habe na dann lassen wir doch
lieber unseren alten Freund präschin zu
Wort kommen
redet viel wenn der Tag lang ist und
seine Tage scheinen in letzter Zeit
extrem lang zu sein anders als enthalten
seine gezielten Provokationen auch immer
einen wahren Kern er weiß nämlich ganz
genau dass wir es mit einem
psychopathischen terroring zu tun haben
mit der Zeit größten akuten Bedrohung
der Menschheit und wir alle wissen
gefährliche bewaffnete Psychopathen darf
man nicht reizen aber man darf sie auch
nicht gewähren und frei herumlaufen
lassen man muss sie unschädlich machen
und aus dem Verkehr ziehen auch als
wichtiges zeichnen andere Psychopathen
und Gefährder der Geopolitik
im Falle Putin Russlands bedeutet dies
leider dass man sie durch den Einsatz
militärische Gewalt unschädlich machen
muss alle anderen Optionen wurden
bereits durch das IPS mit nach 2014
verspielt aber natürlich muss diese
militärische Gewalt auf kluge und
bedachte Weise zum Einsatz kommen man
muss mit den Psychopathen auch ein
Psychospielchen spielen das meine
Freunde ist kein leichtes Unterfangen
aber am wichtigsten ist es nicht nach
seinen Regeln zu spielen sondern nach
den eigenen denn wenn man nach den
Regeln des Psychopathen spielt hat er
schon so gut wie gewonnen die Regeln
kann aber nur diejenige bestimmen der
sich verdammt gut vorbereitet hat und
nach diesem Video wissen wir dass dies
auf die Ukraine zutreffen
[Musik]
also was meint ihr denkt ihr das ist den
Ukrainern gelingen wird die russische
Front in zwei Teile zu spalten wird die
Krim wirklich ein vorrangiges Ziel sein
oder im Gegenteil nur ein
Ablenkungsmanöver wird das Spiel des
Westens aufgehen wie hoch wird der Preis
dafür sein und welchen Preis würden wir
dafür zahlen müssen wenn wir den Regeln
Putins nachgeben würden und als
Bonusfrage werden die USA am Ende ihr
langstreckenraketensystem doch noch an
die Ukraine liefern wie immer sind wir
auf eure Diskussion zu diesem Thema
schon mächtig gespannt ich hoffe dass
euch dieses Video gefallen hat und ihr
vielleicht auch das dabei gelernt habt
falls ja gebt uns bitte ein Like teils
mit euren Freunden und diskutiert ist
ausgiebig mit ihm natürlich freuen wir
uns auch jederzeit über eine Spende von
euch wenn du Zeit dies ist Projekt
weiterzuführen den Link dazu findet ihr
in der Videobeschreibung macht's gut und
bis bald
[Musik]